[Music]
hello and welcome to the ai coffee break
today miss coffee bean has prepared the
definitive introduction to graph neural
networks
or gnns in short but
miss coffee bean are you not a little
overconfident
to say definitive you know i just wonder
if
okay here we go i
always struggled with graph neural
networks in machine learning classes
but one day i could not get around them
anymore and had to learn them
they are such a huge topic in machine
learning for a very obvious reason
graphs are everywhere and not just here
artistically represented in the stock
image
let's take for example air travel
flights from origin to destination with
perhaps a stop in the middle
can be represented as a graph where
airlines try to maximize the number of
passengers
transported by trying to minimize fuel
time and other costs navigation systems
on smaller scales
on street maps also do graph
optimization for getting you to your
destination
other examples of graphs are personal
connections or graphs that social media
apps
live off or even text is also a graph
if we think of it not as a sequence but
if we
analyze it linguistically in terms of
the dependency parts for example
images are graphs too in multiple senses
we make one kind of graph interpretation
of images when we
represent each pixel as a graph node and
each pixel is connected with an edge to
its
neighbors this is a very regular kind of
graphs
a grid another more semantic graph
representation of an image can be
in terms of the scene graph where
objects and entities are nodes
connected by the relation in the image
one more example
and we finally get to graph neural
networks in nlp
people are interested in the knowledge
graphs comprising facts about the world
like these true facts here
well i hope you are now convinced how
ubiquitous graphs
are so of course we need a deep neural
model to handle these structures right
well graph neural networks are the deep
and neural solution
to this they come in many shapes and
flavors
but we want here to stay simple and
explain only the
graph convolutional neural networks
if you understand this one you will also
understand the basics of the other
architectures because they work
based on the same principles and graph
convolutional neural nets are not hard
you just have to apply this formula
iteratively and you are done
oh wait what well if that's it
let's break it down to every detail
first let's talk about the nodes
they are denoted here with h where h
is a vector representation of the nodes
these vectors are chosen depending on
the application
they can be word vectors when working
with knowledge bases they can be pixel
values when working with images
they can be a combination of image
features and word vectors if working
with scene graphs
in graph neural networks the idea is
that we have initial vector
representations for our problem
but we can do even better if we take the
neighbors and relations into account
so in principle we update our initial
vectors
using information in the graph structure
and get vectors that represent the
problem better
so the key is not in the initial
representation
of the nodes but in how one aggregates
the representations of the neighbors in
order
to get an even better representation
than the original
this is why we apply this formula
recursively to get
another better vector h at each time
step
only the question now is how do we
exactly get this better representation
first when computing the new
representation we want to keep something
from the old one
for example when working with a
knowledge base that
truthfully says that miss coffee bean is
a star
when computing a new vector for her now
knowing that she is a star
we still want to keep the knowledge of
her identity
this is why we take the old
representation and multiply it by a
weight matrix
deciding how this previous knowledge
should be transformed
but how do we know this weight matrix
well we don't we let the neural network
decide for it
we train it on our given data of node
labels edge labels or other predictions
from the graph structure
when training with these objectives the
neural network learns to make right
predictions given the new
representations
so it better should learn the weight
matrix that helps to get this
new representation this is how we decide
on what and how to keep
from our original representation now we
also want to aggregate the information
from the neighbors
so we take the representation and also
let the neural network decide how to
transform it and what to keep from it
for being able to solve the given task
for example node label prediction
and here is where the magic of the graph
convolutional neural networks happen
in the aggregation function by this sum
we say that we sum over all transformed
neighbor representations
by c i j we mean that we normalize the
vectors differently for each neighbor
but this is not really important because
crucial here is that
the normalizing sum here is a
permutation invariant aggregation
function
what now well this means that however we
aggregate the information from the
neighbors
the way we do this has to be insensitive
to order
because there is no intrinsic ordering
to a graph
how would we ever decide if we take note
4
or node 2 first so we don't decide
because we take a permutation invariant
function delivering the same result
given any order another example for a
permutation invariant function would be
the product or the maximum function
because they do not depend on argument
order
and because we aggregate the information
from the nodes
similarly to how we do in c and n's
convolutional neural networks
this is then called the convolutional
graph neural network
of course the name convolution is
misleading
because the convolution in images is not
permutation invariant
you can check it but still it is a valid
operation
if we regard images as graphs because
images are a special type of graphs
where the order is given so yes the name
convolution is misleading but it is how
it is
and here we are if we apply this formula
iteratively at each time step we learn a
better graph representation
comprising node information also from
neighbors
and their neighbors these new informed
and refined representations
should be then suitable to be used for
the new task of
for example link prediction node
classification
or even entire graph classification and
many other tasks
gnns have been successfully applied in
the medical domain for example
to predict side effects due to drug
interactions
or in numerous graph optimization
problems like the traveling salesman
problem
or for various applications in knowledge
graph prediction
they can be even used for predicting
object trajectories from video
these applications are just a few from a
very big list
where there is a graph so everywhere
there can be a graph neural network
solving the problem
so this was it we hope that now you have
a better understanding of graph neural
networks and are curious enough to go
out and explore the topics of gns by
yourself hey
do not forget to like and subscribe see
you
[Music]
you